[Music]
hey what's up guys i'm kvd here so okay
you may have seen on twitter over the
past couple months a bit of a series
unfolding uh for those of you who don't
follow there which you should by the way
but if you don't this is the background
so i think the galac adult story is
probably the most recognizable or
familiar of them all so
uh gal gadot you already know probably
an actress wonder woman super popular
i'm sure a very nice person
she has a twitter unless the celebrities
are on twitter obviously in this day and
age um part of her twitter is that she
is a huawei brand ambassador so you know
she'll have tweets about how much she
loves her huawei phone well as you may
know twitter has always kept the data
about what client or what device you use
to tweet from you used to need like a
third-party app to show that data but
now it just shows up in the regular
twitter for iphone and twitter for
android apps so it's public so one day
i'm in an uber and i notice
gal gadot is
constantly tweeting
from an iphone and not only that she's
tweeting those ads those sponsored
huawei posts from an iphone so i don't
know just like the image of her uh
tweeting about how much she loves her
huawei mate 10 pro
but from an iphone i thought that was
pretty hilarious so i screenshotted it i
tweeted that
and it blew up there were articles that
started getting written about it a legit
made headlines i guess it was a slow
news day that day uh people from huawei
ended up reaching out to me about it
emailing me how did you find this is
this real could this be a mistake but it
was a real screenshot uh and eventually
a gal gadot or whoever was running her
twitter account at that time blocks me
all right so this whole thing goes by
then a couple days later people start
sending me
links to her tweets saying hey look
she's tweeting uh the same stuff but
from android sure enough i go back and
i'm unblocked and i can see all the
tweets again and all those twitter for
iphone tweets are gone and they're all
placed by the same ads but via twitter
for android
well done now i get it these celebrities
or at least most of them don't tweet
themselves when you get to a certain
level you have a team of people that run
your social channels and you know those
people can use whatever phones they want
but i don't know there's just something
funny about an ad
for a phone
being shared via
a directly competing phone i don't know
maybe i'm just immature but that's still
hilarious to me so i thought that would
be it for a while um but very shortly
after
uh it started to pick up again and we've
seen this before but it started to seem
to happen with a little more frequency
so indian actress anushka sharma she's a
google ambassador she's always tweeting
about how much she loves her pixel she's
been seen in public carrying a pixel
phone and she tweeted her latest was an
ad for a shot on pixel tweeted
via twitter for iphone then a little
later a real verified samsung account
tweeted an official announcement for the
galaxy note 9 when that phone came out
from an iphone and then razer razer's
official announcement tweet for the
razer phone 2 when the embargo dropped
and that phone first was revealed to the
public on their account
that was tweeted
from an iphone and there was another
samsung account another original account
tweeting an official ad for a samsung
phone via twitter for iphone then the
official huawei twitter account probably
one of apple's biggest competitors in
asia uh tweeted a happy new year post
but via twitter for iphone so at this
point all these are just blowing up
because every single time it's like how
hard is it to just avoid using an iphone
for your ad for your android phone you
could use literally any android phone
and it would say twitter for android but
these people still getting caught using
iphone there's even an article about
whoever posted that huawei new year's
post from an iphone they deleted it and
then reposted it from an android phone
but whoever posted it
got like their their pay docked and
their position was demoted or something
weird like that there were real articles
about that
wow so at this point twitter police are
basically in full effect um people
basically sending me these left and
right and i know people have been asking
hey do you have like a team of people
dedicated just to finding these oopsies
uh no it's just uh a lot of you guys
have a pension for sending me them as
soon as you notice them but there's all
kinds of others uh carl pay ceo of
oneplus has tweeted from an ipad linus
fellow youtuber uh he tweeted his video
all about why android is better than
iphone um
from an iphone there was even one
instance of apple tweeting from an
android uh this was a bit of a stretch
it's not like it was an ad for an iphone
or anything but it was an official
account from apple the apple music
account replying to some tweet by ariana
grande but it came from an android phone
i guess it's just hard to imagine
someone who works at apple and runs
their social accounts choosing to do it
from an android phone kind of weird but
like i just i can't jump on all these
posts anymore i can't be
full enforcement police on every single
little infraction you know how many
times somebody who is supposed to be a
product ambassador for one thing tweets
from another thing i can't be on all
that steph curry for example he's been
multiple times in ads for uh the palm
phone he's an ambassador for that um he
tweets constantly from my phone i'm not
gonna call him out every single time
there's no point anymore like there are
hundreds of examples of people uh who
don't have social teams who really do
get paid to act like they use one thing
and then days later go back to using
their iphone i don't have time for all
that the twitter police must maintain
its integrity we gotta stick to people
who are who are sharing ads for one
product
directly from the competing product
those
those are still gold so that's that's
basically the summary of the whole
twitter police thing by the way this is
not a new phenomenon this is something
that's been happening for ages and ages
one of my favorites an old classic near
and dear to my heart is a long time ago
oprah
you know noted influencer
was was caught tweeting an ad for a
microsoft surface tablet
from an ipad
not even another iphone from a directly
competing tablet i thought that was
amazing but one of my favorite things to
come out of this someone has actually
built a tool that allows you to scrub
through twitter accounts i'll link it
below just because someone shared it to
me uh you can scrub through twitter
accounts to see not only like the dates
of tweets and hashtags used but the
client
that that person on their twitter
account has been sharing from the whole
history of their account so as you can
imagine i've sort of taken the liberty
to go back through some of the twitter
accounts of note and check them out one
thing of note gal gadot has tweeted and
has left a hundred plus tweets from an
iphone on her account but i'll give her
the benefit of it out and maybe they
came from uh pre-huawei sponsorship days
but my favorite thing i found out from
this uh that samsung mobile nigeria
account uh when i originally called them
out with that one tweet from an iphone
turns out they had 300 plus tweets from
an iphone on that official samsung
account no one really cared but i called
them out
shortly after they deleted or suspended
the entire account
then a couple hours later it reappeared
and when you submit that account in for
scrubbing again there are now
zero tweets from an iphone from that
account so they went back and deleted
all of those tweets which is actually
really impressive you didn't see
anything
right so what have we learned from all
this
uh-huh that celebrity endorsements
shouldn't mean much not that they
already meant a whole lot but the
original point of the mechanics of a
celebrity endorsement are hey look
people want to be more like this
celebrity we'll pay him or her to say
that they use something that way other
people will buy that thing so they'll
feel closer to that celebrity like
they're doing what that person does
but celebrities don't really care so the
people managing their accounts they'll
take money to say they use something but
they don't really use it and in the
world of tech it's just too easy to get
caught bottom line it should be so easy
so easy to avoid this
but until then people are gonna keep
doing it you can't hide from uh the
twitter police
that's been it thanks for watching catch
you guys in the next one peace
by the way if you ever catch me tweeting
an ad for an android from an iphone i
give you full rain to reach out and slap
me through the internet but it'll never
happen
because it's just too easy to not do